a mixed 8 has no borders it's an
ideology of hate that's spreading across
the world from its headquarters in the
city of Raqqa in Syria it's here they
plan their campaigns against all
societies but Sky News has discovered a
research and development wing more
sophisticated than was ever imagined
this is the former Equestrian Center in
Raqqa here they're developing a
remote-controlled car it's a prototype
scavenged and put together in their
workshop the idea is that this can be
replicated by sleeper cells abroad this
is a bomb and they're filming how it is
made some of the trainers and designers
make no effort to disguise themselves
this man one of the most hands-on is
Turkish
but Sky News has identified men from
Syria Tunisia Egypt Pakistan Sudan and
Somalia undergoing training to take
abroad in countries where suicide
bombers are scarce remote-controlled
bombs are an ideal weapon to avoid
detection they need a driver the
mannequin is coated in wild and Ratliffe
oil to distribute heat a self-adjusting
thermostat will bring the mannequin to
the same temperature as a human body
lasers are attached to the head to
create eyes the vehicle is scanned with
any type of heat detected it will admit
the signature of a human being if you
had a vehicle driving towards you and
there was nobody in it that would
probably result in a course of action I
long-range standoff attack but if the
sensor identified what it believed to be
a human being in that vehicle then
potentially that vehicle could gets
sniff accan ly closer before any you
know counteraction would take place so
they've really thought about the tactics
of the different security forces
they've second-guess the potential
courses of action those security forces
might make and they've come up with a
solution it appears that you know can
potentially counteract that so it's very
very clever what they've done in this
section of the video a man explains in
Russian that all types of explosive
materials can be used if they have the
right fuses they have an array of
materials available to make bombs
TNT improvised missiles and stockpiles
of plastic explosives remember this
video is for the terror group itself
it's not the usual Islamic state
propaganda in Turkey an Islamic state
defector confirmed that a top-secret
trading program was known about in Raqqa
his home town the program he says was
about attacking countries in Europe and
further afield an attempted recent video
a team Turin mentioned interfere in
their wound illogical Ali Devin came to
posture aluminum to thicken Shan Maharaj
Champa Champa - Akbar miss a Methuselah
taken to theory ajumma heart a koala
Hamlet actor must remove dust remove
Surya well at American crossing the
Turkish border
skirting its military presence Islamic
state has been sending terror trainers
north towards Europe for months
passing through predominantly ethnic
Arab towns they can virtually disappear
all stopping them at the remnants of the
Free Syrian Army but in these streets
that an is member was captured with him
a hard drive containing hours of
training videos was passed to Sky News
it illustrates some of their plans and
unveils their technical abilities
what's clear it's a bit lamech state is
working on weapon systems and weapons
that'll help them to continue their war
in Syria and Iraq
but more importantly they're also
developing skill sets and weapons that
can carry out more spectacular attacks
in other countries in North Africa in
Tunisia for example in Russia and also
in northern Europe this is effectively a
jihadi Technical College and they're
employing some of the finest technical
minds they can get to achieve their
goals the research teams may be well
qualified but they pay scant regard to
their own safety the work though in this
room reveals one of the most shocking
developments ever known about Islamic
state they're converting a missile from
a jet fighter and making it into a
surface-to-air missile there's a
heat-seeking water can take out a
passenger jet
99% of the time these missiles hit their
targets for decades terror groups have
had weapons like this most of the parts
are good for 20 years or so what doesn't
last though is the thermal battery which
is the call of the weapons operating
system they can't be repaired and
without it the missile doesn't work it's
sorted these groups for years what this
film reveals is that Islamic States
researchers have made an alternative
thermal battery it's a huge breakthrough
for them
Western weapons experts are reeling I
think this is one of the most
significant intelligence finds in terms
of daesh what we've seen is with their
typical propaganda videos they're very
very high quality
they're you know designed they're
produced to
- you know inspire people and to
effectively touch the nerves of anybody
who's viewing them you know they're done
in a very specific way with this
training footage it's very clearly
purely designed to pass on information
pass on the progress in the research and
developments areas and it gives us a
very very good insight into where they
are now what they're aspiring to do and
crucially the diversity of the types of
threats that we may face so I would say
it's a an intelligence gold one this is
altogether more serious than anything
we've seen from Islamic state so far a
jihadi college training foreign fighters
to fight in other country while also
developing missiles for the war in Iraq
and Syria and elsewhere it was suspected
but never seen although this film and
its horde of intelligence has been
intercepted it is just one there will be
copies and there are hundreds if not
thousands of jihadists eager to learn
stuart ramsey sky news on the
turkey-syria border